[Música]
e
[Risas]
[Música]
y
[Risas]
[Música]
sí
y eso está bueno
[Música]
es también un problema
captará de nombre
[Música]
estas aves tenía buenas de bío bío bío
y ahora quiere ver frío
[Música]
gracias
buenas noches
somos pablitos yo soy la negra
y yo te re nerviosa
no sé ustedes pero eso
vamos a hacerle honor a drexler
bueno somos argentinos yo sé que no se
nota
pero si lo somos y va a ser una milonga
como hizo drexler antes
pero la nuestra es una milonga argentina
[Música]
ah
maestras hombreras
esta puesta
hay vez mala que sea mal
2 a 3
weidmann
en fin
a la lluvia
sí
no me mueve
[Música]
bueno tengo libertad
y
[Música]
e
y
[Música]
mira
hachís mamá eso merece muchos piensan
[Música]
no lo ven
a esa ciudad deseada
[Música]
d
l
[Música]
con temor a muerte al fallecido
si te sientes contención
[Música]
y
i
[Música]
[Aplausos]
vamos a una canción ahora qué
yo tengo una y tengo dos hijas pero una
una de ellas cuando tenía nueve años
esto hace cinco años
salió a pasear a los perros se fueron
paseo con los perros y cuando volvió
pablito y yo estábamos ensayando en casa
en el salón y cuando volvió nos dijo
a mí a mí me encanta de estos paseos con
los perros porque cuando salgo es como
que me vuelvo parte de todo
y mi cuerpo se pone a bailar y el viento
y yo nos volvemos uno
yo milito novela nena no
ya mira vamos vamos a escribir la frase
de esta porque está guay para una
canción no entonces un día que hagamos
una canción la sacamos eso quedó ahí
tres cuatro meses más tarde estábamos
componiendo y sacamos el librito donde
teníamos la frase de la canción hicimos
la traducción la pasamos al inglés y
cuestión que la nena estaba ahí a nuca
se llama y se emocionó y se sentó lado
nuestro empezó a tirar frases para
seguir la canción no sé cualquier cosa
no sabía tenía un momento de inspiración
y entonces no veo como que nos empezó a
molestar entonces dijo mira chico ya
está bien ya vas a tener tu momento de
fama
ándate a jugar ya estabas tomátelas
el descenso super mal se enfadó y cuando
se estaba yendo nos miró y nos dijo pero
ustedes dos de que van si yo vengo acá y
con un puñadito de palabras los barros a
los dos
esa se transformó en la última frase de
la canción
y en el nombre de nuestro disco
la total
un puñadito de palabras
[Aplausos]
ella caminó a través de la cuerda
y se volvió parte de todo y en un
esquelético y lento baile
el viento y ella se volvieron a
experimentar más si became aforo
[Música]
athena pone su dance to live
break toda clase de spray
[Música]
fidel partidos pequeños de consumo
sí
soy uno
thatcher o no
[Música]
y
ah
[Música]
y
ah
[Música]
siguen los simples lo que pasa
llamándolo
lleno
[Música]
utilizarlo
pero yo siento
[Música]
m
ante el alavés
[Música]
soy uno de esta ley
ante esto estás puedo leerlo panchos
agua lleva
[Música]
[Aplausos]
final raro
a mí me gustaba
no es que no sabíamos cómo terminar y lo
cortamos y nada está
final suspenso
[Música]
llevo tanto tiempo sin dormir hojeando
despacito el tictac del reloj su salud
es a amarillas no me dicen porque estoy
desesperada porque un sueño y con una
razón cada vez es que todo sigue igual y
esas sonrisas de humo que me mirará al
pasar yo prometo que no voy a inaugurar
la discusión ni a intentar tener razón
de dónde estoy ni a dónde voy
cuando me gusta situación yo prometo no
manejo mis palabras si me encuentro
sinceramente no me busques en un día
a mi rincón
[Música]
tantas marionetas ocupando mi lugar
tantas caretas cuales me pongo si me
pongo yo lo dejo todo igual y dónde
están los papelitos con respuestas están
todos en el refrigerador y si me dijiste
lo que hacer esta mañana me olvide yo
sólo sé de vez en cuando si tomármelo de
espacio no apurarme un poco más es
cuestión de averiguar aunque de lúcida a
correr y cuando misas sin extensión
mucho prometo no me alejo a mis palabras
si me encuentras sincera no me busques
en un día con
de ser todo confusión yo busco en las
esquinas un cachito de decencia y
compasión en el camino
y además si la cosa no va más
yo giro en mi destino recogiendo los
trocitos que dejé en algún lugar cuando
me cruza sin estación dicho prometo no
manejo mis palabras un encuentro sin ser
a mí no me busques algún día como hoy me
quedo en mi rincón año 2002
y cuando miro ya sin función yo prometo
no manejo mis palabras si me encuentro
superada y no me busques en un día como
hoy te queda mi rincón
y no me busques en un día como ver
me quedo en mi rincón
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y
nosotros éramos una banda grande
éramos los chicos los patos
y nos fueron dejando
sí
nos fueron dejando no sabemos por qué
y nos quedamos pablito y yo solos ya lo
superamos no se pongan tristes
la cuestión es que bueno el señor
bajista super bajista que nos tocó el
bajo o cantar el re fácil y toca el
ukelele
cuestión de mi hijo bueno ahora usted es
reemplazar a toda la banda
toma medio esto
me comprobó que el hermano que era
me dio los cacharritos más cacharritos
teníamos un teclado y me dijo bueno
tocar el piano
bueno pasamos la melódica cuestión yo
termino haciendo un mamarracho
y el señor genial no pero bueno yo lo
que puedo
estas canciones
en mi canción favorita
es una canción que habla de que yo se la
quiero dedicar porque ahora con todos
los problemas que hay que hubo en
realidad siempre de inmigración
se la voy a dedicar a los más de 7000
inmigrantes que han muerto en las aguas
del estrecho en nuestros últimos 30 años
y quiero quiero crear también que el ser
humano en el fondo es compasivo
y que en algún momento nos vamos a
despertarnos y que vamos a
esta canción habla de las fronteras y de
que de que en realidad las fronteras no
existen porque somos todos seres humanos
y somos todos iguales y debajo de lo que
ahí fuera hay un esqueleto y es el mismo
para todos y vamos todo el mismo lugar
aparte
no eso no va a cambiar así que nada dice
[Música]
e
[Risas]
[Música]
todo
chávez pidiera montaña me ha enfriado
[Música]
me he hecho con su haber
d
para la para
para captar
para ti
para papá
para
[Música]
esta crisis y son la pata de una coupé
de giro aviones no tuvo la libertad de
servicio sabe más que tú
[Música]
e
y ahí
[Música]
este gadget con su trapo
lluvia ve tu celular de poder
delante de jessica vemos para que no se
pagó
si me quieren acompañar cantando es
súper fácil
[Música]
[Aplausos]
para qué
ah
y cantar
para para
[Música]
para papá
andará
[Música]
un repetorio la vista
[Aplausos]
se nos acabó el tiempo
bueno nos vamos
vamos a ser una última canción esta
canción se la escribimos a un
a un colega nuestro de tarifa en un
borracho un loco un vagabundo
hay unos pocos en tarifas son parte del
decorado
y son muy buena gente la mayoría están
sufriendo un montón pero bueno este es
tito jorge se llama le decimos tito y
esta canción se le hicimos a ver
acá
[Música]
junto a la estación de boletos
a la que ha visto como su propia gente
levantando los sólidos en su vida había
participado en montevil y de eso sabe
tanto luego esa misión
me dicen que mantuvo visitado por todos
esas son las cosas
[Música]
a la vista de todos
me llevó preso ya nada me detuve china
[Música]
visita a gaza no hable sobre esa zona
sus hojas de normas e irlas por todo
media
visita mi nota vayan todos lo apresaba
con la nave
que irlas por todas
[Música]
dire de aspecto de marca
las autonómicas
[Aplausos]
[Música]